I want you to imagine
a situation like this,
where you're setting an Event listener
after the event has already fired.
What happens?
Nothing, if this event
doesn't fire again,
then this Event listener
never gets called.
Now imagine you're using promises and
you set an action to occur when
a Promise resolves here which is after
the promise has already resolved.
Guess what?
This will execute.
Compare this to Event listener example
where the Event listener would never get
called if it's set after
the event already fired.
I want to quickly show you some code.
This is a promise constructor, and
you'll be learning more about
this in the next video.
This methods, resolve,
settles the promise.
A promise can only settle once.
So in this scenario,
the second resolve is doing nothing.
Nothing's going to happen,
it's going to go by unnoticed.
Compare this to events.
An event can fire many times, but
a promise can only settle once.
Promises execute in the main thread,
which means that they are still
potentially blocking.
If the work that happens inside the
promise takes a long time, there's still
a chance it could block the work the
browser needs to do to render the page.
If so, the frame rate of your
app is going to suffer, and
you'll probably hear your
users complain about jank.
Promises are not a pass for safely
executing long running operations.
They're simply a technique for
deciding what will happen when
an asynchronous task settles.
Think of them as try catch wrappers
around asynchronous work.
Okay, it's time for a quiz.